well i've done other
films based on letters
most notably
dear america letters home from vietnam
so i was just reading the new york times
one day and i saw that this book had
come out that was based on letters
people wrote jackie after kennedy was
killed
and i thought hmm i know how to make
letter movies
so i got the book and i read it and i
was
blown away by the letters
so i just using the handy dandy internet
i found ellen
and called her
she's in boston and i said hi you don't
know me my name's bill
i've done some letter movies
and you know i did a film called dear
america she said
i know dear america
i love that film
and i said oh well then this is going to
be an easier conversation than i thought
because i was sort of seeing if you
could give me the book for free so i
could go out and try to you know get
them
get the movie together
and she said it's all yours i was she's
actually said i was hoping you would
call
you know and
you that work in the movie business know
about the movie god and you know that
sometimes he smiles down and sometimes
he doesn't and that was one of those
days where he smiled down you know of
the 800 000 letters that
that the white house received
at some point on most of the letters
were tossed out the kennedy library has
3 000
put away in boxes and ellen discovered
them
on by happenstance we're searching
another film and uh
and they said we've got a few uh
condolence letters from from uh
to jackie kennedy and she started
reading a few of them and immediately
realized
what she'd landed on and um
uh and of course she dropped the other
book project yeah exactly and she now
she's got 250 letters in the book and we
picked out 21 letters
uh one actual one of the letters uh is
not in the book but it still was uh in
the archives yeah actually the last
letter there dick santoro's letter
uh
i was not in the book and i called ellen
when we were now early on and i said you
know ellen i don't have an ending for
this movie um
you know
is there any letters you didn't use
and she said well bill obviously i used
all the good ones you know the ones i
liked and i said oh okay okay but that's
for a book for me is there anything and
she says well there's this one letter it
wasn't to jackie
i said well i can finesse that yes yes
and she said and it was just way too
long for the book it was pages long
and i said well we have the technology
to fix that so let me see the letter and
that was dick santoro's letter
which i thought
you know was the perfect button on the
film and actually speaking of that there
is one
you know
obviously these letters
in context are oftentimes sad but i
you can't just make a movie that's a
bomber i mean i can't anyhow
bergman maybe uh
but
i was trying to lutheran yeah
i was hoping that i would see some ray
of hope somewhere or something you know
positive out of all this misery um
well let's talk a bit about how you you
were there at the beginning then of this
project that you had worked together
before on a film the two of you yeah
we've worked together on many films on
many films no i call i call my producer
ann
and then seconds later i call mark and
then we can make a movie okay so you
were there right from the beginning and
with your producer and you had your
subject and then you went out and were
able to get a lot of money it looks like
relatively for a documentary
no it didn't work like that this was
down on the show i was waiting for the
night
this thing was down on the cheap no
if anybody noticed there's no music
composer we use all stock library music
yeah very little pieces of music
the martin luther king's i have a dream
speech isn't in there we couldn't afford
it um
walter cronkite crying when he says
couldn't afford that's twelve thousand
dollars i was going to compliment you on
using unseen archival footage that was
not
necessity is the mother of invention
there's all that that's true but
actually
when i had this idea and i wrote a
treatment and i went to my manager and i
said this is what i want to do next
there's got to be somebody in hollywood
that's you know going to want to do this
and he says
we'll call stacy
as in stacy snyder and i said well i
don't know stacy snyder she didn't know
me he said no she's a nice guy call call
stacey i said well i know i'm not going
to call stacey and she said well then
email her here's her email address email
her
so i emailed stacy on a
thursday
i got a call from stacy snyder's office
friday you know she said this sounds
interesting bill what do you have i said
i have a treatment i got a book should
send it over
i sent it over that day
and monday morning she called and said
stephen and i love this we're going to
make your movie
which i thought well that was the
easiest movie i ever got made
but
what they really meant to say was we're
going to put our names on it and exact
produce it and help you get the money
and it took us a year to get the money
uh was very hard the
i think people people kept asking me
well what's the new revelation you know
is there a new babe has come out of the
woods you know and i kept saying that's
not that kind of movie it's it's
it's not about
that stuff it's about how we felt and at
the time
and nobody was interested and finally
discovery
gave us a tumble
thank goodness
and perhaps in speaking about
the movie god or goddess
the timing now becomes perfect timing
for the 50th anniversary of the
assassination
that had occurred to me
and to discovery i imagine
so you've got your book you've got um
how did you then choose the letters
well bill did that uh with this
brilliant script that he wrote before
we before we really did any uh
pre-production or anything and based on
the script when i read it i got very
excited about it
and said and could see that we probably
could do the whole film without shooting
anything we realized that early on other
than scanning the letters that was the
only thing really in high def in this
film everything else was archival
footage from the 60s there's no
recreations no oh no no but there's one
story no i don't
i shouldn't say i don't do recreations i
don't like it i avoid it like the plague
sometimes you know you gotta in this
particular case there was one letter the
one from henry gonzalez the
mexican-american postman
which i just loved that letter i just
because because people felt such a
kinship with the kennedys and you know
so many you know my dad a lot of other
dads
you know fought in world war ii and they
came home and they got married and they
had kids and they went to work and you
know
they saw
a mirror image of themselves in the
kennedy family
and
henry's letter was just the perfect
example of that
and clearly with the way he's talking i
looked at i said okay i'm going to have
to get home movies
from gonzales and if i have to fake them
i'll have to fake them because that's
that's what i got to do
so
we had to clear all these letters i mean
the book had a clearance for the book
but not to make a movie so we had to go
back to the people who owned the rights
the letters and and get them
to agree to give us the rights to make a
movie
and part of that conversation was always
do you have any you know still
photographs from that period that we
could use
and then i would throw in but no one
ever had i said you know and do you by
any chance have any home movies
and i was talking to henry's daughter
because he's he had passed away a few
years ago
and she said oh
dad was an amateur cinematographer we
have boxes of home movies
and again i went thank you
and then of course when i got those
boxes of home movies
i had already was pretty familiar with
the kennedy stuff
and i saw that we actually had
identical shots from the two families
and i just
you know
that made me happy and it made mark
happy too we have we were able to
juxtapose pinatas riding horses you know
playing on swing sets
it really is amazing uh when bill was
going through some of the uh the the
regular rate movie uh on a little
rewinder and seeing some of the imagery
just like film school back and saying
you know we're just kind of you know
i you know just pick out more than we
need right now but in when i started
seeing some of it after we bumped it up
to hd it was
i was i had already seen the footage
we've had from kennedy from the kennedy
library we kind of call it the home
movie footage and
i could see that we were in big luck
here